Turkish president retro type erdogan
says he wants to continue pushing for
peace in Ukraine despite the recent
escalation another one was speaking at a
regional Summit in Kazakhstan the
Turkish leader is meeting Russia's
President Vladimir Putin there turkey
has retained close ties with both Moscow
and Kiev and has offered to organize
peace talks
erdogan says his goal is to bring an end
to the Bloodshed as soon as possible
we are all closely experiencing the
effects of the crisis in Ukraine on a
regional and global scale
I always say that a just peace can be
established with diplomacy that there
are no winners in war and no losers an
equitable peace
DW's Julia Han is following those talks
in uh from Istanbul I asked her what has
emerged so far
well so far Terry we haven't heard any
details about erdogan's renewed efforts
at diplomacy or what Vladimir Putin
thinks about it when the two leaders
briefly appeared before cameras they
focused on energy security and Putin
proposed that Russia could export more
gas wire turkey to European Union
countries after the north stream
pipeline leaks essentially turning
turkey into a hub for Russian energy for
Russian gas of course he's well aware of
the fact that many European countries
have been scrambling in recent months to
secure alternatives to Russian gas let's
listen to what Vladimir Putin said
we might consider the perspective of
building yet another gas pipeline system
and creating a gas Hub in Turkey for
sales to other countries first of all of
course European countries
only of course if they are interested
well that is of course the big question
if they're interested Putin also said
that his proposal would mean that prices
could be determined without politics his
spokesman said that turkey reacted
positively to the idea but we haven't
heard anything directly from erdogan yet
the Turkish president only said that he
was looking forward to intensifying ties
with Moscow from energy to security and
of course statements like that are
viewed with a lot of concern in Western
capitals
so we've got poutine focusing on energy
there but erdogan saying in advance of
this meeting that he wants to search for
a diplomatic solution to the Ukraine war
what exactly is President erdogan's role
in in all this
well Adam still sees himself as the key
mediator in this crisis he has performed
a balancing act between Ukraine and
Russia since Russia invaded the country
in February turkey is a NATO member but
it has so far refused to join Western
sanctions against Moscow even though I
should add that the Turkish government
has clearly condemned Russia's
annexation of four Ukrainian regions
last months but the Turkish president is
trying to continue this Balancing Act he
is hoping to bring together volorumia
zelensky and Vladimir Putin for peace
talks because he says diplomacy is the
only way out of this and ahead of
today's meeting there were reports about
a Turkish proposal to host talks between
Russia and the West on Ukraine in the
weeks to come but of course the big
question is how realistic is that
because neither Russia nor Ukraine seem
to particularly want talks right now
indeed uh that's a that's one question
another question is How likely is it
that poutine would listen to erdogan
given that turkey is part of NATO
well the relationship between Vladimir
Putin and is a very uh complicated one
but Russia has essentially become a
pariah in most of the western world so I
do believe that Vladimir Putin needs at
least a few Partners a few allies and
that's why I think he's still the
talking to Rajiv Tai badon so Putin
needs to add one in a way and add one
needs Putin at least when it comes to
the economy the Turkish economy is
ailing we have skyrocketing inflation
rates here so for turkey tray ties with
Moscow energy corporation is is very
important
Julia thank you so much good to see you
again our correspondent Yulia Honda in
Istanbul